hello and welcome to GameSpot Super
Mario maker to review my name is Jake
and I'm here with our reviewer Peter
Brown amen
Super Mario maker 2 it is the sequel to
Super Mario maker it's exactly what it
sounds like people can create and share
their own mario stages this time around
there is a story mode yes and what a
story it is it's not really that special
of a story but the story mode itself is
great because what it has is a hundred
levels made by Nintendo in the Mario
maker toolset which means these are not
the sort of things you would normally
see from Nintendo but it's still got
their creativity and brain trust behind
it so a lot of fascinating stuff in
there you know you go online you play
other people's stages so we're gonna be
hit or miss the ones in story mode
they're all hits like they're all really
really good so that's been a great mode
to play I just in general and then there
is there's like almost an overworld
right like the premise is that you're
rebuilding Peach's castle yeah and your
kind of stuff that area it's it's a
weird sort of like side-scrolling slash
3d I could don't you want to call it
tuna hefty it's weird but yeah it you
can't do much other than walk back and
forth talk to characters and get levels
from them turning coins rebuild pieces
of peaches castle it's all you know
rapping to make an excuse for what
you're doing there's a couple of cool
nods in there like the dog from Mario
Paint who's also like you know in the
game and like in the maker part of it
but you know he has a nice little cameo
and you get him a dog house which is
actually like Koopa shell I think and I
don't know it's cool but really the
stages are the stars yeah I think one
question I have is about the unlockables
yeah so Mario maker one had that sort of
divisive unlock system where you had to
start your Wii U every single day for I
think five or six days or something like
that
baby steps do you see do have everything
from the start or do you unlock things
throughout the story like should you
play the story before you get into
making no I wouldn't say so you do there
are some things you can unlock by
beating the story it's just a few I
think only if I remember correctly it's
either just one or two items that you
can use in the maker toolset but they're
not hugely impactful not like the sort
of additions that intended
has made otherwise so I would say if you
want to make stages go right in if you
need a break
the Stormlands a great place to just
play some fun levels well speaking of
making stages one another new addition
is Yama Mors dojo which apparently is
pretty in-depth teaching new players how
to create their own stages yeah if I
remember correctly I think Yamamura was
present in the 3ds version had sort of
like a light tutorial system but here
there's like a series of courses not
like Mario courses but like study
courses you can do to become a
thoughtful capable creator and it does
start off pretty simple right like
here's how you achieve certain
objectives when it comes to practically
building a level but then it gets into
sort of like philosophical things like
what is your mindset when you go to
build a level like how do you approach
the broad concept and you know whittled
down to the the individual things you
want to focus on it's pretty cool now
respect and there's a funny little
banter between the pigeon and Nina I
think her name is the female character
who's like the budding Mario maker
standing in for you it's definitely
helpful yeah what about the actual
interface itself you can build stages
docked and I feel like that experience
could be vastly different considering
one you can actually use your finger or
stylus to yes if you have a stylus
making on the switch itself and handheld
mode is the most ideal way to do it
without a stylus you're gonna run into
some clumsy things here there like at
first it didn't bother me too much but
the more that I started to try to make
sort of intricate levels I would find
that drawing straight lines or even just
trying to grab an individual tile would
often result in you know miss placements
when using my finger registering on
wrong blocks and kind of screwing up my
stage you can go back really easily just
by holding down the B button but
definitely play with the stylus if you
can unfortunately don't have one that's
super reliable so I'm still trying to
figure out what that's going to be
whatever you do probably don't make
stages docked because you have to use
the buttons on the controller obviously
without the touchscreen and its clumsy
and especially given how intuitive and
straightforward it is to drag-and-drop
and build levels in handheld mode going
from that to a controller and dock mode
it just doesn't make sense your brain
takes too long to figure it out and I
think the only way you'd want your
reason you'd want to do that anyway is
if
you were building a stage with someone
else but yeah primarily just building
handheld mode that's the way to go so
what about the gizmos and different
objects you can place is there a wide
variety does it feel like there's a lot
people can make with what with the tools
that are given yeah I mean that's that's
what the community has been showing me
so far playing all their levels I mean
there are a lot of things to choose from
and they all have like pretty
predictable behaviors if you've played a
lot of mario games before but you know
you placed an object then you can hold
down your finger or the stylus on it and
it'll give you options to like transform
it in a few ways or you can combine it
with other items those things aren't
totally explained to you upfront because
there are so many combinations that's
half the fun though is exploring and
seeing what you what you can come up
with quite often the community will
teach you that through the levels that
they're making and uploading so often
you'll discover something when you know
trying to make one and that feels kind
of cool there's clearly a lot of depth
there to explore so it's gonna be a
while before I understand everything
well speaking of the community how have
the community built stage has been so
far great there's a ton of stuff that's
been brought over from the original
Mario maker and I know like some things
have changed the community is taken note
of but I think for most players like
myself we're not gonna notice you know
the the intricate little trick that
people used to use missing from this big
impressive stage that they've uploaded
the game has been out less than a week
and there's already more levels than I
can keep track of she isn't surprising
at all and they're great fun you know
it's just it's this endless portal to
more Mario and Mario that like you've
probably never seen before because in
the hands of creators things are gonna
come out a lot different and they do
compare it to what Nintendo might make
yeah is it pretty easy to find those
stages and upload play all that kind of
stuff yeah you know there are lists that
are curated based on popularity and
whether that's all time or like within
the recent window which are called like
hot courses you can also see new stages
that like no one's played ones that were
just uploaded there's a ton there's also
detailed search you can use if you want
to whittle down by you know what game
it's based on the sort of theme that's
in use the type of stage like if it's an
auto running stage or one built with
like puzzles in mind so yeah it really
feels like if you just want to play
Mario you can kind of go there and find
something for you and probably something
you didn't know you wanted to so one
thing they added with this one is the
multiplayer co-op competitive modes
there's match May
it sounds like there's some issues with
that though it's been bad for me so far
so because there's no transparency to
the matchmaking I can't see or rather I
can't dictate what sort of people I get
matched up with which normally that
would just me say me be saying like okay
only match me with people on the west
coast in America I don't know where
these people are coming from but I do
know that the lag that I'm playing with
is robbing the game of the fun you know
it's if it's competitive right you don't
feel like you're an even footing because
you don't know who has the same lag you
do but also Mario you know it's a really
precise game a series rather like when
it comes to platforming and when you're
dealing with lag like that precision
just goes out the window so it almost
feels like why am I even playing this
when I have all these other amazing
stages to play you know on the other
hand like I don't know that Nintendo
really wants this to be a focus for the
game I don't I don't know but you know
random stages are selected for the
multiplayer matches which means that you
can't really make a stage and say it's
just for multiplayer so you get stages
that aren't really a perfect fit it
which is all to say that like all things
considered multiplayer feels like an
option Nintendo's put in there just to
say like yeah if you wanna play that the
players fine but really you know we
think the the solo play is the thing
because that's what everything is
tailored for that's what's been given
the most attention if I had one wish
multiplayer apart from the matchmaking
you improve I think what everyone else
says is that we want to be able to play
with our friends first and foremost now
there is like the local option where you
can play like in the same room with
someone that has their own switch but
online would be better especially cuz
you have to pay for it tonight so what
did you give Mario maker to score wise 8
out of 10 I think it's it's a really
fascinating game it's you know if you
play the first mario maker you're gonna
feel very at home with this there are
enough innovations that make it feel
fresh and new and like it's worthy of
being a sequel rather than just an
upgraded port you know I think Nintendo
gets a lot of credit for what they've
done with the interface to make Mario so
accessible to you know all these people
that are making stages but really it's
the people making stages that have made
this game so special I think it's really
cool that we're gonna be able to engage
with this game for the foreseeable
future and I really hope Nintendo you
know
is pretty smart about how they improve
the game and about how they decide which
stages they may have to take offline
because I know that was a problem in the
past we'll see what happens here
but so far so good they've done a really
great job with it and the community is
doing even though that was Peters review
of Super Mario maker - for more reviews
features and news stay tuned to game
spot
[Music]